نشرت مجله فورين بوليسي مقالا رات فيه ان
الجدل بشان الحرب في غزه قد يؤدي الى
عواقب انتخابيه حقيقيه في دول عده بالعالم
فمن المقرر ان يتوجه نحو 40% من سكان
العالم الى صناديق الاقتراع العام الجاري
في اكثر من 40 دوله وفي العديد منها تعمل
الحرب على احداث او تفاقم الخلافات
السياسيه بعد ان شهدت هذه المرحله معارك
ضاريه بشان حريه التعبير ومشاحنات
دبلوماسيه مكثفه في الامم المتحده
وارتفاعا في جرائم الكراهيه ضد اليهود
والمسلمين والعرب اما صحيفه الجارديان
البريطانيه فتحدثت عن تصاعد المعارضه داخل
الاداره الامريكيه حيال سياسه الرئيس
بايدن تجاه حرب غزه تشير الصحيفه الى انها
تحدثت الى العديد من السياسيين الحال
والموظفين في وزاره الخارجيه الذين
ينتقدون نهج الاداره ويقول بعضهم انهم
يحاولون احداث تغيير من الداخل بينما اوضح
اخرون ان الرئيس بايدن يتبع نهجا في الشرق
الاوسط لا يلتزم بالتوصيات التي يقدمها
خبراء السياسه وفي مقال بصحيفه جيروزالم
بوست قال الكاتب ديفيد برن ان الدرس
المستفاد من حرب غزه هو ان النصر المطلق
لم يعد ممكنا كما كان الحال في عام
1967 فقد اصبح خصوم اسرائيل اليوم اقوياء
للغايه والقيود معقده جدا بالمعنى
الجيوسياسي ويضيف ان اليوم التالي بالنسبه
لاسرائيل في غزه يعني بدايه التعامل مع
لبنان باعتباره ساحه المعركه التاليه في
الحرب المستمره من اجل امن اسرائيل في
الصحف الاسرائ ايضا نقرا تحليلا نشرته
صحيفتها ارتس وجاء فيه ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي لم تبدا بعد بالتخطيط
لليوم التالي لانتهاء الحرب في غزه يتعين
عليها ان تقرر كيفيه ترتيب الامور على
الحدود الشماليه ذلك ان هامش الخطا الصغير
بهذا الصدد يمكن ان يتيحوا مجموعه من فرص
التصعيد على الساحه اللبنانيه مما قد يؤدي
الى حرب شامله سيناريوهات ما بعد الحرب
تناولتها كذلك مقاله في موقع ذا هيل بقلم
ايتن شرنوف قال فيه ان الدوافع
الايديولوجيه لاعضاء الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ووجهات نظرهم المتطرفه ومواقفهم السياسيه
تحملهم على اتخاذ قرارات مثيره للانقسام
ويضيف الكاتب ان الافتقار الى التماسك
السياسي والوضوح الاستراتيجي
داخل القياده الاسرائيليه يعرقل المداولات
الجاده بشان سيناريوهات ما بعد الحرب في
غزه والى تقرير نشر في صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز ويشير الى ان شعائر دفن الكريم باتت
ضحيه اخرى في غزه يقول العديد من السكان
للصحيفه ان الجنود الاسرائيليين لم يسمحوا
لهم حتى بتغطيه الموتى كما تنقل الصحيفه
عن الدكتور محمد ابو موسى مختص الاشعه
القول ان المحظوظين من الموتى هم اولئك
الذين لديهم من يدفنهم فيما صرحت طواقم
طبيه للصحيفه انهم اضطروا في بعض الاحيان
الى حفر القبور في باحات
[موسيقى]
المستشفيات